[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel your host
this segment and this is your show
America so give me a call at
8825 5225 we'll talk about your life and
your money and whatever's on your mind
whatever ails you we got some fun news
last night my new book Breaking Free
from broke is officially a number one
National bestseller so thank you so much
to everyone who pre-ordered who
purchased who has read the book who's
listened to the Audi book it's because
of you guys you know we can uh write
books in a in a cave but it's way more
fun when it impacts people out there so
shout out to the team to uh to publish a
number one bestseller we do that a lot
around here and we we can take it for
granted if we don't just take a pause
and celebrate and that's all thanks to
our amazing fans out there and people
who have been sharing this telling their
friends about it saying you got to check
out this book it's going to help you win
with money in 2024 so uh I'm I'm a
turtle on a fence post here at Ramy we
have an amazing team that makes this all
happen and I I just did my part so it's
an honor and I'm humbled and grateful
this hour and Joey's going to kick us
off here in Greenville South Carolina
Joey how can I help
today hey um I had a question about
paying off my debt in cash um and I want
you guys to try to convince me to pay it
off in cash when I make more money in
interest with that cash being in a high
yield savings account than I do on the
interest rate on the loan o so that you
want a spirited debate here is what
you're looking for kind of approve me
prove me wrong yeah okay well I'll see
how far I can get you sound like you you
found a wealth
hack a little bit I I guess you could
say how much debt do you
have so I have
$144,000 left on uh it was an initial
$25,000 personal loan at
2.99% back in
2020 um and the the terms were 5 years
uh with 18 months of deferred payments
okay
and it's at 14k now still at
299 yes and how much money do you have
in
savings I have about $34,000 in cash and
$50,000 in stocks and mutual funds and
then about $55,000 and a
401k all right so what are your
goals my goal is in about a year from
now 12 to 18 months to purchase the home
okay and so is that what the C cashes
for and the stocks would you cash the
stocks out to use as a down payment
probably not I would I would just keep
saving I'm saving a lot of money uh
every month now on the cash side on the
cash side so cool I would continue to do
that until I had a big down payment to
put down and what's your
income I make about
120,000 awesome how old are you 24 dude
you're crushing it what are you doing
for work I do engineering way to go
great field and uh that's the top in our
millionaire study that was the top
career was engineers and uh it sounds
like you're on the way so you want to
buy a home you've got this personal loan
debt what was the personal loan debt
for uh it was just a career starter loan
uh through USAA that I got um from being
in the Air Force a while ago cool all
right so what's the payment on this
personal loan right now it's
$468 a month
W now if you freed that up let's say you
paid off you have the 34,000 in cash you
pay off the 14,000 that leaves you with
20,000 in cash and you free up
$468 yes so I I've crunched the numbers
a little bit and if you don't mind I'll
go through them um and just stop me if I
get too in depth or if you have any
questions but between now and there's 33
months left on the note so between now
and 33 months from now the total
interest that I would pay on the
$14,000 is just over
$600 and then the um interest that I
would earn on the $144,000 sitting in
that account in my high yield savings
account would be about $2,000 over 33
months and then the third calculation I
did was uh if if I drained the $14,000
out of the high yield savings account
and then increased my saving amount per
month by
$468 then I ironically after 33 months I
would have $166,000 total in that
account which equates to be you know the
initial
$14,000 plus the 2,000 in interest so
you're saying either way you get to the
same result exactly so why not pay off
the debt you've burned more brain
calories figuring this out you you make
too much money to be spending this much
time nerding out yeah that that is true
so like this is living in your head
rentree regardless of the interest rate
like you're too smart and successful to
even be playing around with this at this
point cuz if this really worked right
Joey like you would just go take out as
much debt as possible at 299 and put it
in high yield savings wouldn't you
absolutely so why don't you go get some
more
debt I I'm not sure if that's an option
I don't know if interest rates for
personal loans can be can be got at 3%
now
but but the theory is if I can make if
you could get a loan at four and a half
and you can make five in your savings
account you're going to go chase the
spread correct and I'm playing a
different game that's that's Checkers
I'm over here playing chess when you
don't have any debt you don't have any
payments it changes the decisions you
make it changes how many brain calories
are used to make these calculations and
so I remember cuz I feel you Joey like I
was 23 24 I was doing the exact same
thing
I was like a pretty I was like well it
doesn't make sense on paper to pay off
the highest you know the highest lowest
balance first I should pay off the
highest interest debt and yet there I
was a broke chucklehead of a 23-year-old
trying to argue about the best way to
build wealth and so I'm not saying
that's you I was way more of a
knucklehead you are far more successful
than I was at 24 goodness gracious
you're impressive and you're so
impressive that I'm just going why are
we even you have the money it's not even
a it literally with a one click this
Situation's over and you're back to $468
back in your life putting in the high
yield investing it building up your down
payment and so I don't know I don't know
why you'd continue this if you just
found out the results the same either
way I would just get rid of the payment
the the only thing and that you know
that is the obvious answer um but the
only thing is that I really plan to buy
the house in 12 to 18 months so I would
you know in 12 months
have more of a need for the cash than I
would uh just saving up more money for
the next 33 months which is the so you
wouldn't actually make that spread in
the end I would right I would only make
that spread if I if I you know kept
investing $468 a month for the next 33
months into that highi savings account
well here's the other thing to think
about Joey that high yield savings
account rate can change at any time your
interest rate is is fixed and so I think
in interest rates will start going down
as things start to cool and so
truthfully you're going to be fine
either way it was a fun debate but
goodness gracious the amount of time we
spent here we could have just went and
made 600 bucks and called it a day and
so I encourage you to pay it off and if
you miss debt for some reason the bank
will always be happy to give you more
and I don't worry about interest rates
I'm more worried about peace over
payments my friend wishing you the best
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel I'll be your host this
segment we're taking your calls at
8825 5225 you call up and we'll talk
about your money problems your wins and
whatever else is going on in your life
Morgan is up next in Raleigh North
Carolina Morgan welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thank you for having me sure
how can I help
today so my question is um I have about
$45,000 in credit card debt um split
between two different cards and oddly
enough the amounts are even um so I kind
of been having trouble with the plan to
really pay it off um so I'm not really
sure which method would be best to use
like either the snowball or Avalanche um
I'm not sure in the interest ratees
pretty high for me it's at 26.2 n%
are these like a retail card really high
um one of them is a city city bank card
um like a cash back card and then my
other one's with Wells Fargo ouch and
are they both at 2629 or what's what are
the two interest
rates um the Wells Fargo ones at about
20% okay I mean because the balances are
if the balances are exactly the same you
can just attack the one with the higher
interest since there's really no
difference here you're going to um
you're going to make you're going to
feel the progress knocking them down
either way are the payments the
same the minimum payment um no the
payments are not the same they're a
little bit different what's the
difference in
payments um the city card is around
higher end of 900 a month and then the
um well yeah and then the wells one's
like 550 okay I wonder if you plug this
into like our DEET snowball calculator
it may tell you um which one would get
knocked down faster if you were throwing
extra money at it and that might help
you make this decision and get you out
of this paralysis
mode okay cuz the key here is you want
to knock down that Principle as fast as
possible and the interest is just making
it harder to do
that yeah exactly because I've been um
trying to double the payment each month
I've been actually my goal is to try to
put at least two to 3,000 towards it um
but it's barely making a dent I feel
like that's the problem with these high
interest rates the higher the rate the
slower it's going to go because that
interest is just killing you so what uh
what other debt do you
have
um really no other debt that's it I own
my car um I have no student
loans um I own my house um I have a
$288,000 um on that that I still owe do
you have any savings but I
put um I have so that's the problem I've
been trying to put all my money
thousands into just paying off these
cards I have about 2500 in the mini like
a mini emergency fund okay um but I
don't have a huge saving because I'm
just throwing everything at these Debs
good baby step one is a $1,000 starter
emergency fund if you have that set
aside and then you have enough to cover
your bills for the month everything else
needs to get thrown at that one credit
card while making minimum payments on
the
other right okay what did you spend the
45,000 on in these
cards um so last year I had a bunch of
some medical issues that unfortunately
wasn't really covered by
Insurance um and then I have I own a
older home so I had to replace the
windows and doors in the home they were
like starting to leak water um I had
some moisture damage so I had a lot of
house things that I ended up spending
money on probably should have waited on
them they weren't like dire but um when
you have the card you're like why
not have you cut up these cards
already huh have you cut up the
cards um no I haven't yet I think it's
time I think it's time we cut up the
cards close the account and then we
start paying off these balances you need
a Line in the Sand where you go no more
Morgan works too hard to be this broke
and these card companies have not been a
blessing to me thus far and they're only
going to encourage me to make bad
decisions with the guys of cash
back right yeah I even try to call them
to ask if they could lower the APR and
they said no I just wanted to ask you
never know I mean we've heard stories
where people just call and say hey I'm
struggling to make this payment can you
lower the interest rate and they'll just
do it um so you can fight them and keep
doing doing that and see if that's going
to help but truly your best bet is just
working your tail off and knocking this
thing out as much as you can so what is
your
income um I earn
$113,000 a year good news um so I'm yeah
so bi-weekly um I'm getting getting
about $3,000 by weekly and I also work a
part-time job that I get about extra
thousand dollar a month at great so
we're talking about 7K coming in take
home yep yeah great so the question now
is uh um as you create your every dollar
budget the goal is how much margin can
we create by cutting expenses by making
more by deeply sacrificing by selling
stuff on Facebook
Marketplace finding the change in the
couch cushions you have to go so
scorched Earth that people think you're
crazy yeah that's what's necessary here
um you've been comfortable for a while
but this Comfort has now turned into
discomfort it's catching up with you
right and so yeah and I'm setting side
about 2500 a month towards my mortgage
and my bills so I subtract that and then
whatever I yeah exactly and then
whatever I have left over I'm trying to
just throw it at the debt are you
investing it all right
now um no I was I did have stock but I
sold it um I actually have a about
187,000 and a 401K Roth IR good well
leave that alone but make sure you've
paused all investing all contributions
until this debt is paid off and that's
going to light another fire under you to
get out of debt faster because you want
to get back to investing you're good at
that you're good at saving money but
right now we got to pay off some debt
and clean up this
mess y are you using a budgeting app
right
now um no I'm not well it starts today
I'm going to gift you one year of every
dollar premium and once you go in there
there's a paycheck planning tool with
the premium version there's a financial
road map that will show you when you're
going to hit these milestones and of
course the budgeting app itself which is
going to help you lay out a game plan
for every single dollar coming in I'm
also going to send you a copy of my new
best-selling book Breaking Free from
broke specifically read the credit cards
chapter I've been hearing so many people
they've been sending me videos cutting
up their cards saying you finally pushed
me over the edge to cut up the cards I
needed a shower after I read that
chapter it gave me the ick and I am done
with that system so Lauren I hope those
two resources help you Skyler will pick
up and we'll make sure you get every
dollar premium and a copy of breaking
free from broke Lauren is up next in New
York Lauren what's going on hey thanks
for taking my call sure how can I help
today um so basically I'm in a situation
now where the last two years I started
to make more money than what I've made
ever previously um I'm 32 I'm renting
right now I gross about 120,000 a year
um and I met about 75,000 after like my
medical and 401K expenses um and I guess
my situation right now is that have
about 6,000 in credit card debt spread
across three cards the interest rates on
them are like
29% um and then I have 8,300 in student
loans and I have an IRS debt so I'm the
pass du the last couple years that's
probably about 4,500 right now and it's
probably going to go up this year so on
top of all that I'm also kind of on the
horizon of looking to try to save for a
house but I just don't really know what
I should do first um my my method that I
thought was to pay off of these credit
cards and then put the IRS debt on a on
a credit card that I
could we're trying to fill the hole by
digging the hole deeper yeah okay well
Lauren you're doing a you're doing a lot
of good things you're just doing them
all at once and you're not going to make
progress that way and so you said you
told me you're investing into your 401k
that's a good thing but now's not the
time because we have a pile of debt to
clean up you told me you want to buy a
house that's a good thing but right now
we still have to clean up up this debt
and the IRS debt needs to go to the very
tippity top of your list you should be
losing sleep over this to the point
where you're like I'm getting rid of
this 4500 this month I'm GNA work my
tail off you make 120k do you have
anything in
savings um no honestly I have about
3,000 in a high yield savings account
right now um and that's really it first
year I made this type of money okay
awesome well this is going to really
help you get out of that fast cuz the
good news is you make 120k and you have
what 167,000 in
debt yeah you're going to knock this out
so fast what percentage are you
contributing to retirement right
now um I'm I I just uped I was 8% last
year and I did 15% this year to try to
help myself and for the tax purpose of
it to lower my tax guess what you're
going to pause investing and it's going
to free up
$188,000 for you to attack this debt in
one year and you're going to be done
probably in a few months if you do that
so I would highly recommend pause all
investing go scch to Earth take a th000
and start knocking away at the IRS debt
then hit the credit cards smallest to
largest balance after the IRS debt and
you will be on your way you'll be dead
free in no time but you got to do one
thing at a time focused intensity this
is the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show hey guys ramsy solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switch to Nets Suite it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll Company
netw Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not not techsavvy that
can be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netsuite today and find out
how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netw su's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm George camel joined by Jade warshaw
we're taking your calls at
88255 225 Jade we've got something
exciting coming up that we've never done
before tell the people George on the
Ramsey Show YouTube channel we are going
live after the Ramsey Show just for
YouTube and we're going to be hosting a
live Q&A all about money and budgeting
we're going to have a special laptop
that's visual it's going to be pulling
up every dollar we're going to show you
exactly how to get a with money
answering all of your questions and it's
going to be Jade warshaw myself here's
what's cool you can either call into the
showa like tradition or you can ask your
questions in the chat real time yeah so
anything could happen it's the first
time we've ever done this but you have
to join us don't miss it January 30th
it's a Tuesday 5:00 p.m. central Time 6
p.m. eastern time go to our YouTube
channel and hit the notify me button on
that bonus Q&A live so that you don't
miss it love it it's going to be fun all
right let's go to Landon in green South
Carolina what's going on
Landon hey how you doing great how are
you I'm all right hey so my quick
question is how do you get to have a
poverty mindset
man are you in
poverty no but the mindset you know I
was raised by a single mother two kids
DED in prison my whole life section
8 um you know I'm 32 now P myself
through school work three jobs I was in
school married now for 9 years years um
I actually just opened up my own
business on the side so I still work
full-time and run my
business
um you're impressive dude I struggle
dude um so you're doing great now but
you still have that it's always knowing
at you like this could all come
crumbling down what's the what's the
fear behind this just well I mean I've
always ah what's the word man um I've
been taught how to survive and not
thrive
so what's what's You're motivated out of
fear or like scarcity you're not
motivated out of
confidence yeah exactly it's not coming
from a place confidence yeah my wife is
very concerned about it um you know
because we want to have a family and U I
want to better you know put confidence
in our kids and uh put them on the right
path and everything else but it's hard
to do that parent that when you don't
believe it in yourself so it's right you
know I'm a Harley-Davidson technician
I've been a technician for 10 years now
11 years uhhuh um started at 11 bucks an
hour um you know now I'm in the 60s a
year working flat rate you know if I
don't work I don't get paid right so
give an example like I hear what you're
saying but it also sounds like you're
moving forward give me an example of how
you feel it holding you back today and
in this moment because I do think that
um when you you grow up that way or when
you grow up with a set of of beliefs and
you're working very hard to shed out
those beliefs um it's not just a light
that flips on and flips off right it's
more like it it's more like that old you
know lawnmower that you have to keep
pulling the cord and pulling the cord
before it gets started right you always
have to kind of like remind yourself
like what do I believe like what's true
and and then you get going so what's
that look like every day for you how is
it holding you back
today h just seeing dead every day
how much debt do you have you
know I have 13 in tuition three in a
credit card seven in a personal
loan um we purchased a new car last year
um you know trying to raise the family
and um
was uh we have 17 on it okay what else
uh we bought it brand new um our
mortgage we're at 200 00 okay not bad
anything else
um no I'm a tool Bill uh but there's no
interest on it but it's still a debt how
much and I'm at 700 bucks on it paying
it and how much are you bringing home
every single month you and your wife
combined what are youall bringing
home uh mine varies uh just because I'm
a flight rate technician so I mean I can
work 80 and Bill 120 or like this winter
you work 90 and get paid for 70
okay my lowest is being a month is right
at two two what and then my w two grand
okay and then that's the lowest uh
what's the highest like what what what's
the norm what if you're busting your
butt what are you making
yeah uh if I'm busting my butt you know
my wife always bust her tail um I mean
we can easily do probably six or seven a
month okay six or 7,000 so I think that
you know we can kind of have a a therapy
session and dig into your past and
figure out what's going on or we can
just look at the math and give you a
little bit of piece through the math
which is you if you guys are making
$7,000 a month are you guys on a budget
CU When I look at that number I go
that's a lot of money there there should
be some margin to really make some
Headway on this debt but if you're not
on a good budget that's not happening so
are you
budgeting yeah we're budgeting my lot
better than added than I am she actually
paid off all first student loans last
year um after getting her master's
degree okay uh are you guys doing this
money stuff
together yeah we are and I
just it
because uh in our checking we do and
then we have a separate
savings um and then with the business I
got a high interest shield on the
business account
um so because I'm real like you know
when you get married everybody says that
you join everything together that's
right in my yeah in my eyes though it's
like you know that was my dad I know she
married into it type of deal um we went
through a lot like we lost everything a
couple years ago uh we moved into an
apartment Place wasn't clean had bed
bugs ruined everything we had Lally
start over on air mattress
um listen and I just when you get
married I I get it I hear what you're
saying when we got married my husband
brought $230,000 of student loans into
the mix right and I only had $34,000 so
I the the idea of feeling guilt and
shame and feeling like listen this
should only just be on me that's a very
real feeling but just because you feel
it doesn't necessarily mean it's right
right and your wife married you and my
guess is if you guys have an open
conversation you've got to take all of
each other the good and the bad just
like John Legend said right we've got
that's just the reality of it as much as
I dislike that song
but that's what you've got to let go
because at the end of the day you're not
going to both of you won't be able to go
as far as fast as you need to go if you
don't really link arms and say this is
what we're doing we're putting all of
our money to pay off our debt and this
is how we are going to approach that
before you get off the phone I want to
make sure they get Financial Peace
University and I want to make sure that
you guys walk through it together
because I think right now it's all
floating around up here up in up in your
head and you've got to get a a p a plan
on paper that you're following because I
don't know how much your wife's student
loans were but you guys paid those off
first for whatever reason and I want to
make sure that there's some method to
this madness and that we're walking
through and we're going okay first we're
getting $1,000 saved next we're listing
our debt from smallest to largest by
balance not interest rate and we're
going to get some quick wins so we start
to build that confidence that you
mentioned earlier that you feel like is
lacking when you start building that
confidence you're going to realize okay
I can do this and that's what builds
that that mindset you've got to get
those wins so that you can start to
build that motivation so that that you
can start building that belief and then
you'll see okay like I can complete this
I can do it and once you pay off that
debt listen can't nobody tell you
nothing it's going to build some
confidence in in you that no one can
take
away and that's coming from someone who
knows I guess another you know to add to
it I mean uh you know the guilt side of
it is just like you know I grew up on
spam baloney and stuff like that and my
wife's parents you know they did really
well for themselves they were able put
two kids through college pay for it I
mean they did really well still are and
I just don't want to put my wife back on
a poverty table you know some she's
never really
poverty you you getting your you you
choosing to pay off your debt is loving
your family well it's the exact opposite
this is the hand that you guys have
dealt yourselves you're in debt it's not
about what you did it's about what you
did next and what you're going to do
next is you and your wife are going to
come together and go okay how do we get
to that dream dream it's by us paying
off debt it's by us saving up getting
the right insurances that's how we're
going to do this and the baby steps are
going to help we're going to give them
Financial Peace University and Landon
I'm also going to send you a copy of my
book Breaking Free from broke to help
you get out of those Chains man you're
changing your family tree it's hard but
it's worth it and it means you're going
to be busting your butt for the next
year or two to clean this mess up you
got to stop letting life just happen to
you and going well we had to it's time
to start happening to your life man
that's right that's going to give you
some hope get connected with better help
too you might need to talk to somebody
that'll help you this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw and
we're taking your calls atle
8825 5225 don't be scared cuz y'all be
sending me DMS every day with nine
paragraphs I'm like y'all call the Ramy
show I cannot sit here in the DMS all
day long it's way easier talking to
people Jade it is but have you noticed
that more and more people are going to
social media for their that's true for
their information especially Tik Tok yes
Tik Tok is Big although I have to say
like I don't spend a whole lot of time
on Tik Tok Instagram Is My Jam but well
can we be real cuz those on Tik Tok know
everyone dogging in Tik Tok cuz they're
on Instagram reals you're seeing the
same videos just 3 weeks later listen
you're you're like a Baptist Church
you'll get there but it's going to take
you a little longer you know what does
that mean George you know it just takes
them a little longer to get get with the
times Jade you know what I'm saying like
they got a drum set but it was about
three years too late you know LOL okay
they got the Contemporary Service but
all the young people have left already
you know what I mean that's how I grew
up Arabic Baptist so I can say that with
pride it's the one and only all right so
here's Jade here's this article I want
to get your take on okay and it involves
Tik Tok all right loud budgeting is
going viral on Tik Tok and for good
reason
yeah okay yeah so Define loud budgeting
for those that don't know okay so loud
budgeting this is me in my own words
it's basically people coming on
Instagram and sharing openly they'll
either openly share their actual budget
or they'll share all the tips that
they're using to spend less they're just
being open for once people for once I
think social media has taken a turn for
the good because we're being real and I
think that this loud budgeting thing is
great because it's really relatable no
one wants to see you standing in front
of somebody else's personal Jet right
like nobody else wants to see you um oh
my gosh look at this new Louis bag I
bought and like you're like influencing
right people want to see here's the
thing in 2024 I'm getting my money right
guys look at my budget you know I'm
spending $500 on groceries you know I'm
not doing any Uber Eats I've decided I'm
not you know I'm doing a no spin month
people want to see that because that's
real and that's really what loud
budgeting is about I've seen a lot of
different types um social accountability
it seems and it's flying in the face of
it's the opposite of quiet luxury that's
how it started I think this guy Lucas
battle started this Tik Tok trend of
loud budgeting but it's it's pushing
against this influencer consumerism
pressure and it's people owning saying I
can't spend money on that right
normalizing Real Money Talk what's
frustrating is that we're out here we're
talking about budgeting every day and
people dog us for it but then gen Z
makes a viral Tik Tok friend and now
budgeting is cool again it's like cash
Dave's like get the envelope system
they're like he's an out of touch Boomer
and then it's like cash stuffing is in
the new viral Trend among gen Z I'm like
they're just budgeting with the cash
envelope this is confusing but this is
one Trend I'm not mad about Jade unlike
Stanley tumblers and Crocs this is a
trend I can get behind cuz this is
really just sharing your money
aspirations and as our friend Dr John
delone would say choosing reality yeah
going I am broke and I'm going to be
open and honest with that and drop the
shame in the guilt and go I need
accountability listen I say all the time
the most powerful thing that you can do
for yourself and for others is start
utilizing the word no and start saying
out loud literally out loud in a
confident voice I'm not going to buy
that because it's not on the budget like
when I started doing that that's when
stuff started changing and not only is
it good for you because it's just it's
an exercise in choice because you're
saying I'm not going to spend that not I
can't afford it and I'm not going to be
able to get that well a lot of times
people use it and there's shame there's
justification you I'm telling my friends
it's not in the budget and they go oh
what a cheap skate instead do it with a
smile and say hey guys it's not in the
budget for me to go out would you guys
be okay coming over and we do a movie
night right that's what this is or you
put you put on the other side of it you
put what your goal is like you say you
know what guys I'm not going to trying
to pay off Deb yeah I've decided I'm I'm
not going to brunch this weekend because
I'm really trying to get my savings up
not only does that reinforce your goal
but like even psychology says you get
that hit of dopamine when you share your
goals it's like o and you feel it and
that makes you more motivated to then
check in again with those same people
because they're going to follow up with
you and be like hey I thought you said
you weren't spending I thought you said
you were on a budget and that's actually
a good thing it's call your friends out
for too long we're just letting our
friends make stupid decisions that's no
friend that's not a good friend I'm
totally with that George I like what
this this says in this article um
suggests you should speak up about your
financial situation and make spending
decisions that support your goals and
match your current budget and needs
that's right that is a trend I can get
behind that's right ask yourself are
these spending decisions supporting my
financial goals that's an adult decision
right there I like that I like that
listen I love that it has a new term
it's kind of like when Tik Tok came out
with cash stuffing and they acted like
they were the first ones to do that
invent the envelope system right your
boy Dave he's been out here 30 years
preaching it listen I feel like we've
been preaching this same loud budgeting
thing here at ramsy for the last I know
for Dave 30 years and for us the the
length of time we've been here and you
just really have to be what I would say
is I think social media can be a great
place to get advice but you do need to
be careful so I feel like I'm kind of
Shifting the conversation a little bit
but I think you have to be careful
because there is a lot on social media
when it comes to money and um advice and
tips that's like uh I don't know about
that like there's there's got to be
method involved so like with loud
budgeting I I can support any channel
George that kind of teaches those like
five pillars like get out of debt budget
get the right Insurance make sure you're
saving you know for emergencies and
retirement and make sure you're
prioritizing giving right that's kind of
like the Five Pillars that you want to
be looking for when you're on social
media however comma and there is a right
order to do those things and I feel like
that's where Ramsay shines is that we're
teaching you the right order to do all
of these things in the right way in
which to go about those five pillars and
that's the baby steps and you really
don't get any better than that it works
every time instead of telling people
well you need to be investing but also
you need to be paying off your debt but
also you need to it's like people can't
make
and even worse a lot of these Financial
creators out there are sponsored by the
credit card companies which is why
they're telling you here's how to
maximize and here's the best card to get
and use my affiliate link and I'm like
are you guys really falling for this you
think they have their best interest at
heart right when you're pitching these
different credit cards so it's
exhausting so be careful follow the
Ramsey crew there's some other there's a
lot of good eggs out there in the
financial Creator world but there's a
lot of bad ones too so but L budgeting
isad with caution but yeah I'm a fan of
this I'm just sad we didn't get there
for Jade how do we create the next viral
Financial trend on social we were there
first listen I saw no I saw Rachel Cruz
sharing real people's budgets I know
I've been on there sharing real budgets
and sharing our own numbers like listen
we're not late to the party we started
the party and we're here to stay that's
right all right Zachary you're up next
in Tampa Florida what's going
on hey guys uh just to take you back on
what you just said I've been debt-free
before I found Dave Ramsey and when
found your show it was finally someone
who gets it a group who gets it they
really get
me I love it I just wish I had found you
sooner a lot of a lot of shortcuts and
how old are
you I'm 36 oh you're plenty young man
people usually say that are like 65 so
you got plenty of time what's going
on well I'm my girlfriend and I are in
love uh we're getting engaged soon and
we're planning to get married and we
have thank you and uh we have some
really exciting plans to both sell our
homes um well she wants to keep her home
and that's the why I'm calling she wants
to rent it out uh her home and mine is
paid off and hers still has a mortgage
and so how much is the mortgage on her
question her mortgage she owes almost
200 on it okay and she bought it about
three years ago in
21 okay and you don't have a mortgage
and she's saying hey why don't we rent
this out I'll come live at your
place well she wants to sell my house
and get a home in between Orlando and
Tampa because she's an attorney that
Services both of those and it's just
easier for her to do that and she wants
to take out a mortgage to get it or
you're going to just pay cash
again I I can't fathom being in debt
again you know after not being in you
know m in debt for so long I just I
can't fathom doing it I'm guessing your
girlfriend is really good at
arguing this was her first house and so
she works really hard and it's her baby
and poo poo
every she worked hard for it she's to
rent it out to stranger she doesn't care
that much about it stranger about to
demolish that thing over time and so if
you're going to do this move you got to
pay cash for the next one we are not
carrying two mortgages
around so that's the line of the say you
get to draw honestly if you're moving
far enough away from that other rental
you need to consider selling that
because you don't want to do that
longdistance landlord deal listen keep
your blanky for emotional support not a
house that's a different decision I wish
you guys the best in your journey
marrying a lawyer like I wouldn't even
dare argue with my wife at that point
there's no debate there oh my goodness
that puts this hour of the ramsy show in
the books she's Jade warshaw I'm George
Campell we'll be back before you know
it
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my esteemed
colleague Jade warshaw and we're taking
your calls America at triple
8825 5225 and I say America but we've
been getting more international calls
and uh it's really fun that's right
International impact Jade International
impact and speaking of the Nations I
have to mention that you're National
number one National bestseller that is
so kind I have to mention it George cuz
the other day it wasn't number one and
then you were like Jade it is now number
one Publishers Weekly hadn't put their
list out yet and we were number one on
in hard cover non-fiction and number
five overall out of all books so that
was come on humbling and I I told him in
the first segment of the show that I
feel like a turtle on the on the fence
post you know the turtle didn't get
there by itself we have an amazing team
here Dave's built this platform so I'm
just a turtle you know I always saw
myself as a tortoise I kind of look like
one your analogies are second to none
thank you I try really hard but thank
you Jade it's been fun and you just
launched a book that was also a
bestseller with money is not a math
problem and it's big making big impact
it is making big impact people changing
their beliefs around budgeting and money
and that's the biggest part it's the
hardest part listen I feel like a weener
in a steakhouse you know there it is
that's my other favorite I know I was
just setting I I thank you for the setup
George it's an alleyoop right there all
right let's go to the phone lines
Mitchell joins us in Anaheim California
Mitchell what's going on thanks for
taking my call sure um so my problem is
or question is I'm trying to buy my
first house I'm 35 years old married uh
Southern California is an expensive
place so it's you know hard to get
started um my in-laws are offering to
provide a down payment of $200,000
toward $900,000 house however the down
payment is not it's not a gift it is a
investment for them um red so it would
be an investment property for them where
you know down the line we sell it they
get 50% of the profit we get the other
50% but we also get to put money into
the home instead of paying rent red flag
red flag red flags all over the
play I can tell you don't feel good
about this by the way you're talking
about it yeah for I mean it's if it
everything worked out financially it
would help us get started obviously um
you know because right now we're paying
3,000 a month in rent sure um it's one
of those scenarios where everything has
to play out just perfectly in order for
it to work and there not be anger or
bitterness or he said he was going to do
this or oh we yeah and yeah so I mean
I'm worried about I mean what happens
when something breaks on the house who's
paying for it what happens when you know
there's taxes due um but what happens
when the house appreciates the 2 million
and now they get a million
dollars yeah and they're stealing your
wealth I don't like any of this man me
either I don't do I don't do strings
attached opportunities yeah and so I
would say that is so kind of you guys
thank you right now we're just trying to
buy our own house our primary residence
we'll maybe get there down the line to
purchase an investment property but when
we do we're going to pay cash for it
that's a big goal for us and if you guys
want to purchase this investment
property you go for it we will support
your decision but they don't pay your
bills and I would not get them
intertwined as you build wealth yeah
definitely not okay definitely not
listen so how long is it going to take
for you guys to save up a down payment
let's let's start thinking about what it
means for you yeah four four or five
years hopefully in that range
and you have no debt with an emergency
fund right now where are you guys at
financially um I have uh I mean stocks
uh
150,000 cash uh more like 30,000
okay and so and no debt my uh car debt
uh
20,000 okay we're going to pay that off
today how would that sound yeah and I'm
I'm also interested in moving this money
out of these stocks is in single
stocks uh exactly yeah what if you just
put it in like a Index Fund for the next
five years that's uh yeah that's
generally what it it is in right now
it's in a a couple different index funds
well is it index funds or is it single
stocks because George asked that
question uh index funds okay so it's
spread around a fund of lots of stocks
in one spot right exactly okay just
check in all right well I like that plan
I like what George said I'm taking
20,000 of your 30k in cash paying off
the car now you've got 10K you can start
building that up to 3 to 6 months and
then anything on top of that you know
keep chuning it away yeah okay and
you'll have 200k of your own in no time
I still think you might need more than
that what's your household
income uh
250 okay and you're going to be buying
in in the Anaheim
area yes okay so I'd start setting a
goal and saying hey we're going to buy
something reasonable for a first home
the first home should always be the
worst home you live in M no such thing
as the dream home when it's your first
so don't try to aim too high get
something reasonable that mortgage
payment should be a quarter of your
take-home pay and that's going to help
you do this in a smart way what does
900,000 get you in Anaheim because are
you still are you still shooting for the
900,000 Mark or not anymore because the
parents aren't
involved
um with the parents involved that's what
we were shooting for without the parents
we'd probably knock you know 200 off
that the town home exactly it's like a
two three bedroom town home that's all
you need my first two homes were town
homes and we have no regrets and I think
too many people poo poo the non- single
family home cuz we wanted the big yard
and we wanted this and we wanted these
countertops and five bedrooms and I'm
like it's just you guys and a dog like
why do you need five bedrooms for it's a
ladder climb the ladder one rung at a
time and town homes still appreciate and
value it's a beautiful thing and there's
less maintenance insurance is cheaper so
there's a lot of benefits to condos and
town homes there and so I would start
there and set that goal get aggressive
about it get that emergency fund but
something tells me you're not going to
go pay off this car today
Mitchell um probably not I I mean we've
been doing a couple thousand dollars a
month here and there just to have a
reserve fund what would it take for you
to pay off the car
today
um uh I mean i' like to have a rainy day
fund of cash well let's put it in
perspective let's put it in perspective
what's your what's your car payment and
what are you putting towards it every
month uh it's 550 a month so it's 550
and you said you're putting a little
extra on it every month if you paid it
off how much extra do you put towards it
every
month um it's kind of just whatever
extra we have so give 2000 one or 2,000
so let's say
1,500 okay so if you paid it off today
you have now freed up
$2,50 that you can put away every single
month into your rainy day fund mhm think
how quickly you'll save money like that
nine months you're done yeah okay just a
little food for thought yeah know I'll
I'll talk to my wife and see if we can
do that then I love it whose car is
it uh hers aha the plot thickens well I
I hope she goes with it and make sure
you present it in the right way not like
hey I called the ramsy show and these
dopes are like telling me to pay off
your car I don't think it's a good idea
but what do you think yeah yeah that's
that's a good point um whatever
$250,000 what do you need car payment
for yeah but it's true like whatever
advice we give people they've got to
ingest it and decide that this is what I
believe too because if you're pitching
it to your spouse and you're like listen
these bozos told me to do then you're
never going to sell it right it's got to
be your idea not our idea car loans are
the number one wealth killer in my book
it's now surpassed student loans Jade
it's a nightmare get out of it Mitchell
you're too successful you're too smart
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw it's
a free call at
5225 well if you missed it we made a big
announcement we've got a brand new event
happening on May 10th and 11th right
here in Nashville Tennessee at the
headquarters it's called Total Money
Makeover
weekend this is exciting and we love a
good live event this is a brand new
event in one weekend you'll get a crash
course on everything we teach about
money we've got brand new talks from all
of the Ramsey personalities including
Jade including Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman
John deloney Rachel Cruz myself we're
going to be talking about budgeting and
beating debt investing and so much more
so no matter what baby step you're on no
matter how long you've been listening to
us this is going to light a fire under
your butt to keep making progress on all
of your goals so if you want to join us
uh be sure to get your tickets cuz right
now we have some early bird tickets and
this is about as cheap as it's going to
get limited time only get your tickets
now for 99 bucks ramsy solutions.com
events and start making plans book the
flight get the hotels budget for it you
got time but it's running out for these
early bird pricing so May 10th and 11th
join us there's going to be live Q&A
throughout the weekend uh smart money
happy hour is going to be live in front
of a studio audience that's you guys
George I have a groundbreaking idea for
my present no I'm not going to tell you
what it is but I'm just letting the
folks know it's going to be different
we're going to break some ground
apparently I don't doubt Jade I never do
because I'd be on the wrong side of that
so join us Total Money Makeover weekend
May 10th and 11th get your tickets Ramy
solutions.com events tell your friend
text your mom bring the whole crew all
right Michelle is up next in Charlotte
North Carolina Michelle how can we help
today h hi it's such a blessing to to
talk to both of you today thank you for
taking my call I have a helck um the
balance on the helck is
$32,000 I have $28,000 in my savings
account and my question is should I take
all take um all of my savings except the
$1,000 and put that towards the balance
of the helck or should I hold back some
of my savings and my concern about that
is um I'm I'm single I'm 55 years old um
I just had to replace my heating and air
conditioning system and I've had some
home repairs over the last few years and
my concern is that my savings would be
depleted if something else were to
happen before I uh saved up my uh full
emergency fund is this your only
debt yes it's your only debt and so
technically you're technically the way
we look at it is like this if the HELOC
is more than 50% of your home then it
would go with baby step six when you pay
your home off but if yours is less which
it sounds like it is at 32 ,000 am I
right yes then it would roll into baby
step two and so for that reason and for
those listening baby step two is paying
off all your debt accept your mortgage
and so for that reason I would do that I
would drop this down I'd knock out this
helck and then that frees up again that
extra money for you to build up that
savings even faster how much do you
make uh about 990,000 a year good
awesome so if you used the majority of
the savings it would knock down the
HELOC to five grand
yes and then you could knock that five
grand out within a few months it sounds
like correct I like that plan M I do too
I don't know how long you plan on
needing to work until but I want you to
retire with some dignity and getting rid
of your debt is going to be your best
option do you still have a
mortgage I do my mortgage is about
140,000 okay so if I'm Michelle I'm
going hey by 60 I want to be completely
debt free what's the plan to do that
right now it's getting rid of this helck
the next few months then it's restocking
the emergency fund to 6 months then it's
going to be I'm tackling this mortgage
I'm going to tackle you know 30 grand a
year for the next 5 years and knocking
this thing out by the time my 60th
birthday we're going to celebrate
because I'm 60 and I'm totally debt free
are you currently investing at
all in my 401k at work um and I I'm at
7% so as soon well I just um I just
paused my my um
uh what's the word contribution I just
paused my contributions yeah that frees
up 525 bucks a
month I'm sorry that that's going to
free up over 500 bucks a month to throw
the
HELOC right so that's why I paus it
starting February 1 so I could put that
towards it and then um build up my
emergency so that was my other question
my emergency fund since I'm singled
should that be 3 months should it be
four months should it six months I like
six months I listen after covid I am
always in the camp of six months always
no one ever regretted having the six
month and so especially with you being
single single income there's just more
risk when you have two people with a
stable income there's less risk so you
could lean towards three but in your
situation and stage of life and you got
you all the home repairs I'm going to go
6 months and that might take you uh on
average it takes 6 to 12 months I think
you'll do it faster you'll do it closer
to that six month range I do to you can
start throwing you know you free up the
HELOC payment and this extra 500 bucks
from investing yeah you're going to be
able to get this thing stocked up in no
time Michelle I also think when you I
think you're at an advantage when you're
single kids are out of the house there's
nobody else to get in the way of what
you're trying to do is what I'm trying
to say so I think that you can go as
quickly as you want to go and get as
intense as you want to get and that's
kind of exciting I love it thank you for
the call up next we have Timothy in
Washington DC Timothy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi George how are you we are doing great
my friend what's going
on well uh first of all I'm just going
to tell you that um I'm the blind guy
that called into your show on the uh uh
the smart money happy hour I think it
was or the special show you did when
your book was released oh yes the live
stream Q&A we did audio that's right you
were saying how great it is to have a
wonderful audio book to listen to
because you're unable to read the hard
cover it is it's wonderful and the sound
effects just added so much fun to it I
was laughing all the way through it
listening to it here's my question thank
you so much so um here um here's my
question so I'm um I'm a single man uh
30 years old um I'm on the brink of
having a fully funded emergency fund
saved I was aiming for 12,000 but after
listening to your book I thought better
raise that to 15,000 just to be safe uh
cuz written utilities worth case
scenario top a little over 2,000 a month
um rent alone 1,700 1725 so and
considering that um considering the
apartment I'm in and the rent I'm
getting I'm actually doing pretty well
apartments around here are running 2,000
or more a months anyway I'm trying to
save up for a down payment on a house
and based on my current income uh gross
salary about 80k a year uh net take home
after insurance and taxes not including
retirement probably about 55k a year uh
that uh after my housing and utilities
and groceries I'll probably be lucky to
save maybe 20 a year um which means
about s to eight years if I want to go
for a 20% down payment and even town
homes in this area or Alexandria
Virginia I've checked online generally
start at half a million dollars so 100
is the minimum I'm aiming for and I was
just wondering um is there a more
efficient way that I could get there or
am I or is this about the best we can
do great question Timothy well you've
been doing great so far and you're at
that home stretch with the emergency
fund which puts you in that baby step 3B
so you're thinking through this the
right way okay the most you can save
right now is 20K I if you've done that
budget and you're going hey there's no
other expense to cut then the other side
you need to go to is how do I make more
how do we get that 80k in DC up to 100K
in DC even if right now that's through a
side hustle or consulting or freelance
anything you can do because that's all
just going to be gravy to get you to 30k
saved that's a different equation now
30k 5 years putting 150 down on a
$500,000 condo or town home now we're
cooking with
gas absolutely and I have been doing
some uh I'm a music teacher on the side
outside of my federal government job so
um I do do a little music teaching on
the weekends uh problem is I've had a
hard time finding students um I now one
thing I did do is uh on my Facebook page
I recently um posted on there that I am
a private teacher uh to my friends only
because uh believe it or not I've gotten
some fishing scams from people that oh
you got to be careful jump in some
Facebook groups locally that's a great
place to start but in the meantime hop
on instacart man make you a th000 extra
dollars a month that's $112,000 a year
add that with the 20,000 you're already
saving I mean that's how you make head
way do something until you can do the
thing that you want to do yeah and check
out that margin's Breathing Room chapter
in the audio book Timothy that's going
to help you I got lots of ideas for
those side gigs for you there this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna
that's her chm story and it could be
yours learn more and join at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Jade warshaw
open phones at
8825 5225 listen George before we go
further I listen I clowned myself on
that last call I clowned our guy Timothy
because he's blind and I suggested
instacart that was horrible boy I I I
dropped the ball Timothy my guy I made a
mistake I'm sorry we need to come up
with some side hustles that will work
for you because the truth is instacart
don't work for everybody so let's George
let's hit him with the list of things
that he can do and Timothy accept my
apology I'm sorry my guy it was an
innocent mistake Jade I'm sorry we've
all been there and uh this show is live
and on the internet forever so I
apologize for that that's just the
nature of the Beast around listen y'all
can come for me in the comments I I'm
ready I deserve it they've come at you
for Less stuff so I just be ready so I'm
going to just go through a list of
things um not just for Timothy but some
ideas that anyone can do and obviously
if you've got any kind of disability
it's going to add a challenging layer
yeah that's fact what I hear in
Timothy's voice is he's willing to do
whatever and he's an overcomer and he's
not scared of work those are the biggest
factors to me and so um I don't know if
there's any U groups like Facebook
groups even for those that have
disabilities or for those that are blind
to the way he can jump in there and hear
from others and
how they've dealt with side hustles and
bringing in more income he's doing music
teaching that's true that's a great if
you can do that you know from your home
you know think about other things you
can do from your home there's a lot of
at home jobs out there one thing that
anyone can do is just sell stuff it is
amazing how much crap we have sitting
around and how much people are willing
to pay for your crap cuz Guess what at
one time you were willing to pay for
that crap let's be honest it's a loop
that's right so sell it on Facebook
Marketplace and guess what if you want
it later on you can buy buy it again
from Facebook Marketplace for about the
same price so uh flipping stuff is also
something I've seen a lot of people do
successfully some turn into a full-time
business yeah they'll go and buy
something for five bucks that they'll
research and go I can sell that for 50
100% big profit so that's another thing
people can do of course Jade you
mentioned instacart there's a lot of
delivery type apps Amazon Flex for
packages door Dash and Uber Eats for
food and so if you have a vehicle and
you're able to drive you got a driver's
license you're old enough then that can
be a great option to go make money uh
tax withholdings Jade is a weird life
hack to get more money back in your life
right anybody can do that if you're
getting a $2,400 refund you can change
your withholdings and get that $200 a
month back in your life now's the time
of year to do that it's the beginning of
the year get the full effect don't think
that was a gift from the government uh
pausing investing is another way people
can free up money in their budget we're
hearing all these calls and we go hey
how much are you investing they go 7%
doesn't feel like much and I go that's
$600 month be used toward your debt and
your goals and down payment uh
babysitting house sitting uh pet sitting
dog walking all of these you can easily
make 15 to 30 bucks an hour and Jade now
that I have a daughter and we hire
babysitters I'm like should I become a
babysitter I'll stay home and watch this
baby for 30 bucks an hour with these
rates okay I know that's right Geor it's
crazy um house cleaning is another one
that anyone can jump into if you're not
scared of other people's dirt I mean you
go in there and start scrubbing and
mopping and you know wiping down and
dusting it's amazing how much money you
could make for one house listen I I
don't know what I would do without the
person that cleans our home so thank you
so much Chelsea whether it's full-time
business or side hustle it's a great way
to do that uh indoor outdoor Home
Maintenance and Repair I mean if you are
remotely handy I'm talking about my
handyman said I go to this wealthy
neighborhood and people hire me to go
change out a light bulb yeah and they
either don't have the ladder the knowhow
the confidence the time they're they're
older whatever it is you'd be amazed if
you just put yourself out there um car
detailing is another one anyone can get
into it's these tasks this everyday
tasks that people don't they don't want
to do like I was out the other day uh
this was in the fall so there was a lot
of leaves out and the kid was scooping
up leaves and putting them you know in
the in the paper bags and I was like hey
can you come over here and do that in
our yard just because out of out of
convenience so there's so many jobs that
you can do that is Con like if you can
think of something that would make
someone else's life more convenient
chances are you can make money at it
that's what it's all about and so
those are just some ideas to make more
there's tons of ways to spend less we
won't get into that today but you got to
be doing a budget first and foremost to
actually make a plan for this otherwise
it can disappear real quickly but some
uh jobs that anyone can do from home
especially those with maybe disabilities
there's a lot of cool like translator
jobs there's uh depending on your skill
that you already have with your career
Timothy's working for the government so
I I wish we get him back on the phone
and go what do he doing currently what
is that skill set how can he offer that
outside of there and private music
teaching is a great way most
don't charge enough I mean you can you
you're from coming from the music world
you at least at the very least need to
be charging a full dollar an hour if
you're not you're I mean minutes is the
starting yeah and then you need to very
quickly be charging 100 and then 150 an
hour well depending on the kid and the
skill level and your skill level you can
really I mean if people are taking this
seriously parents are willing to pay the
last voice lesson I took was $200 an
hour I took the lesson wow and look at
you now one of the best voices
there it is uh so there's a lot of
things you can do a lot of uh gig
websites out there like Fiverr and
upwork and freelancer editing proof
reading writing there's a lot of things
now I wouldn't mess with some of these
dinkier ones like people are like should
I take these online surveys for 10 I'm
like I some of that's just not worth
your time yeah listen I know a lot of
people who are doing virtual assistant
jobs and that is like they're making
major Bank doing Custer service jobs too
just answering phones helping walk
people through stuff and there's a lot
of jobs out there that's right so just
some ideas again I would uh depending on
what you're able to do and your skill
set you just got to get creative get the
old juices flowing sometimes people turn
it into their full-time gig yeah I think
that's how a lot of people's um
self-employed business starts is they
start with something small that they
like that they're good at that's a
convenience for other people and because
they they're good at it it just starts
to grow and there's a need for it and I
you know that's how it starts a lot of
times well especially from the music
world we're both both musicians and so
I'm thinking about Timothy there's room
in the licensing world I mean if you
just license your music for TV films
weddings that's what I used to do Jade
as a side hustle and my biggest hit was
Ford used my two of my songs on their
YouTube channel and I got an email
they're like hey are they they don't
have much budget are you okay with
$3,500 for them to use these songs and I
was like I think that will do abs yeah
we I can that's fine yeah or a lot of
times the instead of paying for the
liing rights to use an actual song they
just want you to make kind of like a
bobo cover of it like I remember my
husband remember that SL the Family
Stone Everyday People oh yeah I am
Everyday People my husb they went to my
husband Toyota and said hey will you
make a bobo version of this make us like
the Great Value so we don't have to pay
Sly in the Family Stone to use their
song wow listen he's got a plaque in his
office for it a't that crazy that's
impressive that's crazy with the plaque
I like that a lot Jade yeah there's a
lot of things people can do and you just
got to be willing to do it cuz most
people they want to just sit on their
couch and just make 50 bucks an hour
listen everyone wants to sit on their
couch what are you willing to do that
other people aren't like that's right
get up and and go you know kill
something and drag it home and so that's
where I look at skill set I had you had
a bajillion side hustles when you and
Sam were paying off debt listen I had
about a dozen yeah you got to get
creative figure out what you like to do
I sold cupcakes and cakes and wedding
cakes and things like that and me and my
husband love animals so we trained dogs
like we learned how to train dogs and
then we went out and got clients and
trained dogs wow so like whatever it is
that you like to do but I have to say
this because it's worth saying no side
hustle takes the place of a core income
that's that's that's not measured must
be on top of yes because if you're core
income like for instance you know I talk
a lot about the side hustles that Sam
and I did but the real issue was our
income like when your income is just so
low yeah you've got to work on that as
well and find a long-term plan to get
that up because the the the fact is
you're not going to want a side hustle
for life and you're not going to want
that to be um the way your life looks
long term so there's two sides of that
coin my funniest side hustle was have
you heard of neelon you know they do
like the ratings for TV media they had a
one called the neelon people meter so I
signed up for this they give you a
little beeper that's listening to the
media you're listening to and that
affects the ratings of radio and shows
and music and so I did that Jade I
turned on my little beeper and I put it
in my pocket and I get a check from like
20 bucks a month that's like wrapping
your car easy get your car wrapped and
you have to drive around with you know
Pony attorneys at law but listen for 500
bucks a month for a season you can do
anything yeah it's easy the problem is
Jade I couldn't fit that little beeper
in my skinny jeans had to upgrade my
pants but hey what are you willing to do
for a short season so that you never
have to do it again what do you doing to
live like no one else now so later you
can live and give like no one else with
Pure Freedom and you can look back at
those side hustles with a little bit of
laughter and have a good story that's
right this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
is your show so give us a call
5225 and if you are enjoying this show I
hope you are would you be would you be a
doll and just hit the share button hit
the follow button leave us a kind review
wherever you're listening you guys are
the you're the greatest marketing plan
we could ever have and the show is free
and what I'm asking you to do is free
just Tak a moment of your time just text
it to a friend hit the Subscribe button
let the algorithm know this is the kind
of content America needs right now
that's right that's all I'm asking for
all right Michael is up next in sou
Falls Michael welcome to the ramsy show
how are you
doing good hey George and Jade thanks
for taking my call sure
so I have two sons one 16 the other 17
they're both in high school working
part-time jobs they are using every
dollar to budget uh every month and
they're doing a really good job for
saving for vehicles my 17-year-old has
paid cash for two separate vehicles wow
um and yeah so he's working really hard
the problem is the the savings accounts
they have are earning 0.1%
interest interest earning more and
they're they're even talking about
investing but I don't know they're both
talking about going in the military and
I don't know if investing is the right
option now if they should be looking at
a money market or a high yield savings
account or what they can do to better
maximize the savings that they have so
that they have a little bit more
available to be able to apply it towards
school or a vehicle or any other
expenses great question and I applaud
you as a father for raising some bright
young men we need more of that in
today's world
yeah thank you so let's separate this
out so there's savings and there's
investing so let's talk about savings
First Savings is for your emergency fund
and for short-term goals so they need to
be thinking out a year from now two
years from now three years from now what
are the expenses we're going to have
that we'll need to cover maybe that's
first month's last month's deposit on
rent maybe that's upgrading car maybe
it's a maintenance fund for the car with
a sinking fund and outside of the
emergency fund and those kinds of
savings goals long-term is when we talk
about investing that's more of like the
five plus year Horizon and I think both
are good things to start um coaching
them on and get get that muscle kind of
get those muscles built and so you're
right on those savings accounts you can
do way better than
0.1% and right now we're at record highs
in savings accounts with you know four
or five plus per in a high yield savings
account so I would move their savings
there and help them open one of those um
I don't really great ones I don't know
can they open one for themselves Jade
I'm trying think if it's custodial still
until 18 17 I think is still custodial
so like a minor yeah okay I think your
name would still have to be on
it okay so that's I would definitely
move their savings to high yield savings
account you can have them do a starter
emergency fund I mean these guys are
about to be adults real quick and so
having a few thousand bucks saved is
great beyond that since they are you
said they're working part-time they have
earned
income yep I would also help them start
funding the Roth IRA and that's not tied
to an employer that's an individual
retirement Arrangement is what that
stands for and you can um work with a
smartvestor pro on that you can reach
out to one of those uh folks on our
website ramsy solutions.com there's also
DIY options you know through like
Vanguard and Fidelity but um there
that's a great way they can you know I
think it's it's 7,000 for 7,000 this
year is the is the contribution limit
and so they can contribute up to 7,000
if they made 7,000 they can contribute
up to 7,000 and if they made more they
still it's still 7,000 but you can't
contribute 7,000 but you only made
4,000 sure would it make sense for them
to follow the the baby steps and do the
15% at this age or because they have
additional funds they should just um go
as close as they can to maxing it out
while still having the emergency fund
and doing some of the other savings I
think it really depends kind of like
what George laid out with those other
short-term goals do they have education
expenses to cover for example yeah I
wanted to ask about that what's on the
horizon and what do you see for both of
them as far as educational expenses or
even living expenses whether it's rent
or because that's going to inform a lot
of this as well moving expenses
knows so right now they're both talking
about going in the military and if they
do that it'll be four to six years and
so all those living expenses everything
else will be covered their health
insurance so they won't have any of
those expenses wonderful if they don't
my 17-year-old is talking about going to
um like a trade school okay and so the
expens won't be nearly as much as the
year so although if they do the military
route that's four to 6 years where it's
covered that's also four to six years
where they can be socking away money for
a down payment when the time comes and
so and also you know kind of blending
what George said with what you're saying
if you did choose to start helping them
put money away you could also think okay
maybe down payment is the next thing
that we're going to do because when we
think about the baby steps cuz you said
can we apply that to them baby step
three is getting 3 to 6 months of
expenses saved for them that's going to
be something very minimal so maybe
they've just got some money set aside
and it's there but if they start saving
for a down payment that's something
because the Horizon is six years from
now you could throw that in an index
fund and let it grow for the next six to
seven years or more until they're ready
for it um if you're not quite ready to
get into that retirement building phase
with them perfect so you've got options
and you can do that in a non-retirement
account like a taxable brokerage account
and just put that in some index funds
for the next you know four five six
years as they're in the military I mean
that's going to that could with compound
growth you know it's going to start to
take hold after a few years but their
savings rate right now is really the is
what's going to be the ticket yeah that
way they can get to it if they want to
and there's no penalty
Associated all right awesome I really
appreciate it absolutely these are fun
conversations to have when it comes to a
16 17-year-old bright-eyed bushy tailed
no debt it's amazing what parents can do
to set their kids up for financial
success yeah uh instead of the the hacks
I've been seeing on social media Jade
which is you should get a credit card
and add your three-year-old as an
authorized user so that when they're 18
they have an amazing credit score so
they can go out and get as much debt as
they
want parents do you understand how dumb
this is and here's what happens most of
the time the parent ends up making
terrible financial decisions and tanks
their kids credit score accidentally
when the kids's 18 they got a 500 credit
score I'm like if you do if you're going
to do anything just take 50 or1 bucks
and just set it aside in in a brokerage
account for them if you're going to do
like just set some money aside why do it
got to be attached to
credit authorized user is the real
wealthy hack Jade it's what the wealthy
people do drives me crazy oh gosh okay
let's get to Karen before before I have
a moment here let's get to Karen Karen
how you doing she's in Green Bay I've
been better um so great to talk to you
guys thank you sure I have a 2016 Kia
Sendo and this week the um the what is
it called the um head gasket blue so I I
owe 10 on it excuse me I owe 11 on it
okay um I can either sell it for an
offer I've gotten up to
6,500 for it I'm getting around 66500
just as solid as is broken with the
known problem is that to a private party
or correct okay um it I can fix it for
about
6700 or I I'm also exploring trading it
I know you're going to say no to that um
trade it in to try to you know get a new
car that um on payments
will yeah girl here's what would happen
you trade it in the dealer gives you
like $2,000 for it and then you're
taking on another 20 and you're going to
increase your debt instead of get rid of
it and they and they probably will sell
me a car worth about four charge me a
few more on the card of yeah yeah Karen
you already know that's not the move so
we can check that one off the list you
need to stay away from car dealerships
with a 39 and a half foot pole right now
do you have any money do you have any
money saved because you you mentioned
getting the car fixed which I I have
like a little emergency fund um five
grand okay okay um um for this kind of a
thing so you almost have the money if
you sold it for 65 and then you took you
know the other 4500 to cover the
difference you could pay off this car
but that leave you carless of
course right are you single then where
do I get a car I am married my H I've
been my I work from home so it's and and
a friend's been helping with driving my
kids for sports and stuff so do you guys
have another
car my husband's pickup okay so could
you go down to one car for a
season just briefly while you save up 2
or
3,000 and then by what
yeah just get a beater and this is
temporary and then when you get another
couple thousand you add to it because
here's the thing when you buy A2 or
$3,000 car it's not going down in value
anytime soon it's already taken the
major hits so just upgrade it little by
little until you get to at least 8 or
9,000 and then that's how we walk up
this ladder of buying a car in cash I
would also go to a bunch of mechanics
and get bids for this cuz I online on
repair pal it's about 1,600 to ,00 bucks
for this repair not 6,500 so I'm not
saying that but look into
[Music]
that
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campell joined
by Jade warshaw and this is your show
America we want to help you take the
right next step with your money and your
life the number to call is triple
5225 Jacqueline starts us off in the
North Pole literally wow Jacklin is this
true
information yes we're hanging out here
with Santa in negative 40 degree weather
right now in Alaska holy moly I want to
pull the will feral you know
Santa basic my nephew actually has said
that and it's it's awesome I it was a
beautiful moment for me because I love
Elf incredible
um well it's funny you guys talked about
side hustles earlier because um I
because we live in the North Pole
there's not a whole lot of resources up
here um and it's very expensive to live
here uh so my husband got stationed up
here he's he's Air Force and um he got
stationed up here and we had some major
sticker shock when we got up here um
because things are just so incredibly
expensive so I started babysitting as
kind of like a side hustle to pull in a
little bit of extra money and it
exploded into this ridiculously good
paying job wow um so we weren't lying
that was one of the ones we
mentioned right um it's earn I I can
earn anywhere between uh $6,000 to
$11,000 in a month um just depending on
the need at the time and how much I can
handle um how many hours does that how
many hours is that equate to just
curious I I usually open from 6:00 a.m.
to 600 p.m. so okay so it's like a
daycare roughly yes yeah 100% okay um
but I also homeschool my my five
children um at the same time so it's has
to like the the workload has to coincide
with what I can you know manage with
that as well so it that's why it
fluctuates so much my question is um
I've been contemplating possibly taking
this business to like turning it into an
actual business um I'm wondering if I
should because of course being in the
military we don't know how long I'm
going to be here um and I mean I could
range anywhere from you know another
year to maybe 3 years depending on my
husband's job um what does that mean
when you say turn it into an actual
business is that like actually renting
space and and turning it into unofficial
daycare okay and the purpose to doing
that would be so that you can bring in
more kids and earn more money yes
because there's a there's a desperate
need like i' I've had people call me
crying because they desperately need to
go to work and and they and I just don't
have any more room and and it's just
it's heartbreaking to have those phone
calls and just say I'm so sorry I just
cannot do anything else um so your goal
is to rent some space locally hire more
people and expand this operation correct
yes okay and what's your question the
well the issue is I I don't know one how
to even begin doing that and then two if
it's even worth it to do that because
like I said we could be gone in a year
or two well when I when you mentioned
that to me assuming assuming all the
other things are in in place for a
moment assuming you don't have any other
debt assuming that I my first thought
would be like okay what's this going to
cost me and I'm looking around at
buildings and then my biggest my brain
goes to Insurance cuz I'm thinking okay
liability insurance is the hardest part
of daycare yeah so that's where your I
believe that that's where your research
is going to start have you ever already
looked into that um I have looked into
that and it it is quite expensive here
um everything here is just like I said
you I mean you take it from the lower 48
anything that costs you know I don't
know $10 you you multiply by about three
um and and that's what the prices are up
here and the question is because you
have such a big if if you have the
demand that you say you have and if
you're thinking to yourself listen I
found this place on the corner I know
what the rent is I know what the
liability insurance is going to cost me
with the demand that I think I'll have
will I be able to offset that in a way
that I can actually make a profit that's
the question got it okay
okay and also be thinking about
Licensing Board of Health background
checks for employees there's a lot going
on here you know getting an actual
business set up business banking and all
of that is going to be a part of this so
I would your next step is just do a lot
of homework and maybe talk to people who
have been in this business locally
because I assume there there's dayc
carees in the North Pole area right yes
there are a few yeah there's just not
not a lot because a lot of them go under
due to the financial stresses everything
you guys just spoke about and I don't
want that to happen to you if that's
happening there's a reason for it and it
just may not be a sustainable business
and that might mean you need to scale
down the business and go all right I can
only take on five kids a month and I'm
going to do it out of my house until we
move and I'm not going to make this a
business or you could figure out a way
that's listen I'm trying to think
through this with you a I hear what
George is
saying there it might be because there's
just a an issue with the how expensive
things are that's why people businesses
are failing or listen talk to those
owners and figure out what was going
wrong cuz some people they're good at
watching kids but they're not good at
running a business right so it could be
that their business sense was off if if
whatever you find out you could also get
with a buddy and be like listen I've
been running this daycare what would you
think about would you be willing to open
your home and run a daycare I'll show
you how I do it so it's almost like
you're uh creating a bit of a franchise
out of this with other moms that you
know and maybe they're opening your
homes and you're helping them get that
started and you're taking a cut there's
a lot of things that you could do here
to get creative but I think the Crux of
everything that George and I are saying
is whatever you decide to do you're
stacking up cash and you're not going
into a bit of debt in order to do it
because right now you're in this place
where it's cash flowing it's making you
a lot of money what I don't want is for
you to get excited about moving forward
get locked into something and feel like
your only option is to go into debt or
take out a loan in order to fund some
aspect of this business Fair
right well I have I have one other
option that I might be able to consider
and there actually the woman that buil
built the house that we currently live
in because we we have no debt other than
our house currently um we we have plenty
plenty put aside for um retirement
considering our ages and we we've got
every like everything kind of our ducks
are are in a row so to say okay um and I
I I just don't want to jeopardize that
because my oldest son is uh special
needs and probably will be um dependent
on my husband and I for the rest of his
life in one sense of the of the word or
another so we're trying to find like my
my original dream was to become a pilot
and I still want to um achieve that
dream at some point um but the the older
I get the less likely it seems that
that's actually going to happen um so
I'm trying to look for Alternatives and
I my my one question to you guys would
be like could I run a business like this
from long distance like say we were to
move excuse me say we were to move and I
could run the business from I would just
sell the business before you move I
agree
I think it's going to be too much
headache and it's going to end up
causing you Financial stress and
emotional stress especially with it's
child care I just feel like that could
it's got so much it's not exactly remote
business you know what I mean right
right so I would just sell it and uh you
hope someone would buy it and that's one
of the reason not go into debt for this
we see too many stories of people taking
on $200,000 in SBA Loans business fails
well guess what you don't get to just
erase that debt now you still owe
$200,000 so move slow move speed of cash
and remind yourself why you even did
this it was hey just want to make a
little extra cash it's okay if you don't
turn this thing into an empire in the
North Pole but what a cool story that
would be that would be amazing she's
crushing it she's on her way all right
thank you for the call Jacqueline stay
warm more of the Ramsay show right
around the corner we'll be
[Music]
back
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw open
phones atle a825
5225 the Ramsey Show question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services in case you're a new
listener you might be wondering what
what does that mean well neighborly is a
family of locally operated home service
providers who are dedicated to giving
homeowners excellent service so start
your search today at neighborly decom
Ramsey today question comes from Kate in
Nebraska she says I've always told my
18-year-old son to avoid debt which
means he has no credit score a family
friend who is the same age recently
tried to buy a car insurance and was
quoted outrageous prices because she
doesn't have a credit score she was able
to get added to her Grandma's policy for
less than a quarter of the price this
has made me think uh he should get a
credit card and build a good credit
score how can a young person get
insurance at a a reasonable price with
no credit history well you know there's
there's something to there's a couple of
areas to this George that my mind goes
to immediately number one the type of
car that's true number one if the car is
paid for or not does definitely can
increase your rate like obviously if you
have a brand new you know
2023 um uh what's a nice car George I
don't know cars like not a Civic but
like a like a sporty sportier car yeah
the
like the color of the car matters like
if you get a Camaro in red listen that
insurance is Bonkers um and there is
just something depending on the state
that you live in if you live in South
Florida and you're a new driver like
it's just going through the roof so
there are a lot of factors there um but
at the core of this question is really
the credit score and that's what I think
that we need to dig in the most because
it's it's one factor so Jade I actually
wrote an article on the Ramsey Solutions
website called Insurance score how
insurance providers use your credit
score so in here
I talk about the other factors cuz
credit score is one factor we will admit
that but there's other factors like your
age the younger you are the more
expensive it's going to be I'm sorry but
teenagers are likely to get into a
fender bender yeah that's not going to
change and so uh you know jenz is
getting the M shaft here um while
Boomers get the gold mine I'm sorry uh
your location like Jade was mentioning
High population areas are going to mean
higher premiums rural areas lower
premiums again it's all about risk for
the insurance company it's not because
they hate you it's all a measure of risk
and lastly it's your history of claims
so uh if your kid has had a fender
bender already their insurance is going
to go through the roof MH and it stinks
so those are a few factors but if you
don't have a credit score there's still
a lot of ways to get a better deal on
your premiums which is pay your your
other bills on time they're going to
look at other payment history and so you
want to avoid those late penalties you
also can bundle you know auto insurance
with other types of Insurance to save
you can raise the deductible if you guys
are out of debt fully funded emergency
fund a higher deductible puts a little
bit more risk on you but it lowers your
premium and uh the other thing Jade is
people will shop with one company
they'll go with some name brand they saw
on a Super Bowl commercial instead of
shopping around so what I do is I shop
with one of our Ramsey trusted Pros so I
get in touch with my people at Xander
insurance and I say hey can you shop the
top companies and tell me what the best
rate is and they these are only really
highly rated companies these aren't Bobo
Brands um but they also may not be the
big ones you've heard of that's true
that can save you big money just going
oh we're not getting a good deal I need
to shop in with an independent broker
that's a good really good point and
there's also a deeper level to this
conversation that I just want to tackle
real quick because the fact of the
matter is when you living a life without
a credit score does is not always the
easiest choice in the moment because you
can always find like a bunch of kind of
like little factors well it'd be it just
be easier if he had a credit score then
he'd just have a lower rate and you kind
of think of it like that and that that
pops up a lot of times think about
renting a car people say oh well if you
you don't have a credit score you can't
rent a car and I'm like you can you may
have to jump through a few more Hoops
like let's be honest about that you may
they may make take more of a a hold on
your account you know all these things
that yeah if you had credit they might
not do that but if you had credit do you
also know what you have is debt so you
can't have one without the other you
know same thing with credit cards people
are like oh it's just easier for me to
just pull out my credit card and swipe
it I'm like yeah that's why you swipe it
so much because it's easier so there's a
discussion here
about it's really what you're trading
you know what I mean and it's like
listen if you're saying I want to set my
kid up for success and you understand
that part of the way that you're setting
him up for success is I'm teaching him
that we don't have to borrow money we
don't need a credit score we give
ourselves credit that we can earn the
money we need we can manage the money we
have in order order to have the
lifestyle that we feel we deserve and I
feel like that's the teaching that's
behind this and when you make that
choice and draw that Line in the Sand
you're also saying to yourself yes you
may have to jump through a few more
Hoops because the fact is our society is
not set up for it doesn't favor the
people who
choose to not use credit it favors the
people who do use credit so there is
that piece of this that you just have to
accept and go listen I'm willing to take
a couple hits sometimes in order to
maintain my peace and I think that
that's what we need to be teaching our
kids is that give yourself credit don't
depend on the credit score oo I like
that yeah that's true and that getting
that affordable used car and have your
kid work part-time to afford the
insurance these are good skills for this
kid to learn and then the insurance will
go down over time as the kid gets older
so uh I'm going to just suck it up and
uh do all those things I mentioned we'll
put the link in the show notes James the
producer can we do that to the insurance
score article that will give you all
those tips I mentioned and give you a
deeper dive on that love it all right
Nick is up next in Providence Rhode
Island Nick welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys uh thanks for having me sure
hey so I was hoping for some advice or a
little guidance um my wife and I uh we
have two young kids under uh under four
years old A 42-year-old just purchased
our um forever home in
Connecticut uh we previously owned I I
had two rental properties previous to
that um holding on to one and we sold
the one that we were living in half uh
and then purchase our new house um I
have some money in savings and I have an
opportunity that if I were to sell my
other rental property that I do have
debt on um I'd be able to pay off my
primary residence um I'm kind of going
back and forth um whether it's a good
idea or not um you know I I um yeah I
just I'm just trying to figure it out
I'm kind of torn a little bit you know
whether to do it or whether to keep the
money and invest it and maybe get some
more rental properties um but I would
have to take on more debt obviously
which I know you know I've been lening
you guys for a few months now and know
it's um you know not really the path you
know that suggested look what do you owe
on your forever
home uh 405 405 and if you sold the
rental what would it
bring so the rentals I could sell it for
550 and I owe 248 so I probably take
home after taxes right around 2
so it wouldn't be enough to actually it
wouldn't be enough to fully pay off your
forever home it would just make a big
dent is that what you're saying yes why
I have uh just under 300,000 on the bank
as well like liquid
cash I like
it from our other rental property that
we had when we sold that half so we only
to pay taxes on half when we sold it how
how much money do you guys make a
year uh so we met around 12,000 a month
um my wife and nurse we moved into the
new house she actually ended up uh only
going to two days a week um and then I
work um I make around 155 and she makes
around 60 now amazing just curious the
rental when you rent it how much does it
bring like what do you profit from it
every month yeah yep so I actually just
handed it over to a property management
company it was Cash flowing around
$2,600 a month so that's after you know
mortgage after what it brings in I
cleared 2500 now it's you know just over
2,000 okay and then I also am just
curious your forever home what's the
mortgage payment on it yeah so it's a
high interest rate uh it's at 3700 right
now listen I I'm what here's what here's
the numbers I see I'm looking I'm like
okay listen $2,000 of cash flow that's
great but if you paid off your if you
sold this rental paid off your home
mortgage now you've got the 3700 or a
portion of that cuz obviously you know
you've got to keep paying your taxes and
whatnot you get that back in your pocket
and now you're turning around and you're
restacking your savings essentially
you're either adding it back to
um your house is paid off so you can
invest as much as you want like you can
literally turn around and invest that
money and I feel like that's the move
that's a lot of money George and the
other option is you guys make great
money if you could stack up a 100 grand
extra you could just pay off your
primary residence from the savings and
keep the rental and then attack that one
next so either either way I like that
plan but let's get aggressive about
making one of these moves happen I don't
think you'll regret selling the rental
and having a paid for house cuz you're
going to be able to get another rental
licky split with that kind of income and
no payments my man this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade War shop
this is your show give us a call at
88255 225 we'll talk about your life and
your money well Jade uh producer James
slipped this on the desk and it's a
fantastic fun article from Yahoo
people are revealing the everyday items
they had to stop buying because they
became too expensive that sounds like a
buzzfeed headline like BuzzFeed people
they have no character limit for these
headlines goodness gracious that's funny
listen yesterday's prices are not
today's prices we all know that and we
all feel that so let's read a few off
and see if they're relatable here number
one concert tickets it's something
everyday things people sto buying
because they became too expensive I
didn't go see Beyonce everybody else was
renaissanc and I was at home M I felt
the same way with Taylor Swift everyone
was Taylor swifting I'm like y'all got
y'all got some money bro folks were
cashing out their 401ks to get these
tickets I just can't St what's the most
expensive concert you've you paid for
recently okay thank you George for
teeing this up I saw you two in the
sphere oh my goodness and I was deeply
disappointed can you tell us how much
those cost because no one has told me is
it like $1,000 it was it everything all
in for both of us it was about $1,000 so
500 bucks a ticket yeah and if you spent
double that you could get even better
seats and I just it it did not not a
$1,000 experience for you here's the
thing it made it worth it because it was
my husband's 40th but on another
occasion I would have been like I want
my money back oh gosh and just imagine
how many people put that experience on
the credit card o Waitz how many people
are like you're you're budgeting for
this trip you know exactly what it's
going to cost you've got you're paying
for everything in cash they've done done
studies George that say you know we
already know that when you put stuff on
credit you spend more because you don't
feel it they've done studies that said
um one of the high one of the purchases
that you'll spend the highest percentage
more on up to 100% more is concert
tickets that makes sense people will
literally pay double the price when they
put it on their C well and I think the
younger Generations are willing to Fork
over more for experiences yes and then
they get the older crowds the Gen xers
and the Boomers with Nostalgia CU now
everyone's got I mean Elton John's on
his 90th final reunion tour I'm like
goodness gracious man yeah but those
tickets aren't as expensive and that's
what that's what I say go watch the old
heads perform like I go see Kenny
Loggins you know what I'm saying like I
go see these old acts because the
tickets are like $7 reable oh my
goodness yep okay that's a good one next
up we've got bowling oh this person said
a few years ago my girlfriend and I went
bowling at a local place it was maybe 60
bucks for shoe rental and 2 hours of
Bowling for two people recently we
checked prices online same rental and
playing time as
$50 whoa for bowling I mean that thing
better come with like a massage while I
sit and wait for my turn for1 15 that's
right that's crazy what's next she says
ads and okay ads being added to Amazon
Prime and Netflix was a breaking point
for me oh what does that mean the ads I
guess it didn't make it more expensive
but it's just a frustrating piece there
that you're paying that much for
something that still has ads well my
thing is Amazon Prime and Netflix the
price has gone up like Hulu to those
like all those little subscription
streaming services it was like I don't
know5 to $8 now everything's like $19.99
if you want in HD otherwise we're going
to show it in black and white in 4x3 in
720 everyone went went into the teens
they went from the single digits to the
teens for sure oh this one's
relatable everyday items that people
stopped buying because they became too
expensive
Airbnb oh anytime I look on Airbnb and I
see all these fees like it's $99 night
but there's a $400 cleaning fee listen
clean it I spend what you need to get it
cleaned because I I need to know it's
clean I'm just saying I usually the only
time I stay in Airbnb if it's with a big
group and we want to do something fun
and local and we're hanging out we did
that in Arizona it was fun but otherwise
I'm just staying in a hotel I'm sorry
you know what I I stay in a hotel
because I feel like there's a corporate
Juggernaut supporting the fact that my
hotel room needs to be cleaned properly
I've seen Airbnb horror stories okay
uhuh so there's part of me that's like I
get hey could you go ahead and start the
laundry for me and while you're at it
there's some weeds that need to be
pulled from the back I'm like listen I'm
not here to do your chores please I'm
paying you for a service okay no way oh
look ordering pizza is getting too
expensive this person says I'll still
order for pickups sometimes if there's a
good deal but no more just picking up
the phone and randomly ordering a pizza
that's my my toxic trait is I'm always
like I am picking up the pizza I ain't
paying for delivery and my wife and
friends like dude just pay for I'm like
it's $4.99 for the delivery fee then you
got to tip the pizza person who
delivered it are we talking about just
basic like dominoes or Pizza Hut or are
we talking about like Uber Eats
delivering a specialty pizza uh I think
this is more the whatever your casual
local pizza place is whether Uber Eats I
don't trust Uber Eats personally and
it's not to down because I know a lot of
people do that as a side hustle you
they're grabbing a fry well and they're
grabbing a fry for sure that driver is
grabbing a fry you mean to tell me if I
go pick up your order at McDonald's and
that fresh hot McDonald's french fry is
sitting right there in my cup holder I'm
not going to reach over and just grab a
couple I have trust issues listen though
we got a lot of people doing side
hustles paint getting out of debt
driving I'm not mad at them keep doing
it our crew they're not doing that nasty
stuff so no our people do it right TR if
you're out of the if you're on this
thing for the right reason gazelle
intensity you're not that person but I
just know that happens out there yeah no
keep support your local listen listen if
you have the money support your local
Uber Eats driver because they're trying
to get out of debt and and while you're
at it pay for my order too I like that
all right next thing people stopped
buying because they became too expensive
is New Clothes someone said tried to
downgrade from the mall to Amazon but
that stuff's mostly trash well Rachel
Cruz's feelings are hurt she loves
shoing you have to know how to shift
through the trash though cuz and I don't
know how so they said I Thrift now it's
not as bad as I anticipated a lot of the
stuff is discarded with tags I even
found a sweater that I'd wanted years
ago that's us on point listen reduce
reuse recycle there you go this girl
said I love this she said my car I just
said screw it I'll work from home and
get me a bike wow come on girl I know
that's good for the body too you know
getting your workout in it's good for
the planet I like it but yeah cars
especially if you live in a city you
know obviously some places you can't
just get rid of your car and bike around
I some climates some locations but a lot
of people that live in an area with
public transportation I'm from Boston
you don't need a car living in Boston
you can get around to most places uh
with the tea call it but let's talk
about just saving money on gas because I
just feel even if you don't live in an
area that you can get from most place to
play like you might have to drive your
car to get to work but you might Publix
is around the corner you might be able
to walk to get your groceries or ride
your bike to get your groceries I think
we need to start considering you know
being a little bit
more creative with our transport that's
good last one on the list eating out
they said not worth the price and the
food quality is not there anymore and
there are smaller portions for higher
prices I agree with that that feels like
a complaint I would leave 100% and
listen I am not buying a cocktail at
these restaurants like if it's a if it's
a very nice fancy restaurant and I know
that they craft very nice cocktails I'll
buy one but if we're going to Applebees
which I RAR you know listen I'm not
going to Applebees but I'm just saying
don't don't buy a cocktail of Applebees
it's when Jade is going to what Red
Lobster and getting a lobster why is it
got to be Red Lobster George the cheddar
bay biscuits you're dipping it in the
lobsterita okay that's disgusting no
that's a good one though I'm actually
going out to eat tonight with my wife
it's our it's our date night and we're
going to a nice like high-end sushi
place and I'm already like I'm getting
ready for this bill Jade listen George
I'm still on Red Lobster I'm still on
Red Lobster and if you invite me I'm
going every time I'm just telling you
right now you can't pass up the cheddar
bay biscuits # notsponsored but it's
true like let's call out that inflation
has made made things more expensive
we're not here to tell you that you're
making it up but also don't overinflate
it and get all big and emotional just
don't buy it anymore half the stuff that
we're upset about with inflation are not
their luxuries Jade I know I know
outside of rent and gas and and normal
Basics like groceries all these still
exists I was in the other day and I was
like oh food's not that bad like you can
get a pill up a buggy for 100 bucks yeah
for me it's the Tipping fatigue like I
feel like some of the reason I've pulled
back on certain things is I'm just the
Tipping fatigue is what got me it's like
all right listen I would usually pop in
and maybe get a coffee but I'm tired of
dealing with the guilt of not tipping so
it's like I'll just save the money on
the tip and the coffee like I feel like
it's that combination of inflation plus
the dialed up and for me it's fees
everything's got fee I'm calling it
fatigue fatigue I like it hey on the
Tipping thing normally you know they
they flip the screen around or someone
else asks you like do you want to tip
your you know bar I've had people
recently asked me do you want to tip
like
meally ask that's the most awkward I
would tip you James you're worth worth
every dime not today but one day we'll
tip you listen I'm all for generosity
but not when it's a requirement and it's
forced that's right hey good stuff this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Ephesians 610
and 11 be strong in the Lord and his
mighty pile and power put on the full
armor of God so that you can take your
stand against the devil's schemes Thomas
so said much of the social history of
the western world over the past three
decades has involved replacing what
worked with what sounded good ooh
that'll make you think that'll burn some
brain calories right there make you
stroke your beard yes good stuff I got
one it's it's not much but it's there
all right this is the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Jade warshaw
David is up next in Chicago Illinois
David welcome to the show thanks for
taking my call how you guys doing today
we're doing great how can we help well I
am kind of planning out the next phase
of my life I'm uh almost 54 years old
and looking at retirement in the next 6
eight years cool and the plan is to
eventually sell all of the assets and
live on a sailboat sail the Caribbean
for about six months out of the year and
when hurricane season hits you put it on
on the shore and live up in a house up
in northern Wisconsin wow I guess I'm
just looking for affirmation that uh I
can do it I can afford it and then the
best plan of attack to uh finalize up
the savings and so forth what a cool
plan that's fun all right so are you
single I am I'm Happily Divorced no kids
okay so you're ready this is going to be
a solo adventure for you no actually the
uh the girlfriend is in on the adventure
uh she is she is going to take care of
the house up wherever we decide to leave
uh live the uh summer months at CU I
figure I'll probably check out long
before she does and then that way that's
she's taking care of on her end because
she's done that and I'm taking care of
the boat and everything on my end wow
when you say sell the assets what does
that
entail um currently have about 10 cars
an airplane uh my house is paid for um
and then as far as what I've got in
Money Market 401ks and type stuff wow so
obviously the the cars will go away the
airplane will go way and uh yeah I'm
going to assume your net worth is in
excess of $5 million oh God no what is
it uh actually just added things up I'm
sitting right about 1.2 okay um so I
mean what are these 10 cars for you just
collect them um yeah I mean I've had
them for I've built them up the
collection over the years uh two of them
are gifts that are going to be gifted to
my nephews when when the age turn
16 um so really I guess have eight and
they're seven days in a week and so you
got to have a spare I guess are they all
are they all paid for like is all is is
there debt on any of this no
everything's paid for the cars uh the
values on the cars total about 530,000
and that's insured value fiber Classics
um muscle cars type stuff and then um
and you're willing to give all of this
up for the dream of the
sailboat well how much does a sailboat
cost I'm looking between 2 25 to 250 to
spend on a boat okay is that used yeah
definitely bu used and the thought
process is actually to uh try to acquire
one in the next 12 to 18 months that way
I've got time to do anything that needs
to be done to it so that when we're
ready to go it goes with us and it's
ready to go and then that way it's also
paid for so the question is though my
question is $250,000 great why do you
have to sell everything to get that
because
you know you said yourself 530 is in is
in the cars alone I don't know what the
airplane is worth and then you've got
this other house that's a lot that's
going to bring a lot of money I don't
know why we have to liquidate everything
when I go to retire things will be
liquidated not not to acquire the boat
um the the plan is to acquire the the
floating asset it paid for and either
and and maybe use it a few times a year
maybe put it out on Charter a couple
times a year but then so that in the
next seven eight nine years whenever I
decide to stop Flying for a living that
I can just sell everything and and move
on to the next adventure and then that
money you just drop into some sort of
investment accounts exactly got ITA how
much do you
make um a little over 200 um wonderful
yeah Bas I fly corporate jets for a
living and you know base is about 190
between extra stuff and if I do any
contract work for a couple thousand a
day I it just call it roughly 200 okay
and just to clarify the girlfriend she
would purchase in her name the house in
Wisconsin or what's the plan for that
cuz I know you said she'd take care of
it but I want to know more that's her
plan that's the plan is that she would
acquire she lives separately in her own
house now so she would eventually either
take out a mortgage or uh she would
acquire the house that we would live in
for six months out of the year six
months out of the Year we'd live on a
sailboat and sail the Caribbean okay and
then obviously uh that way you know that
house again she's going to live longer
than I will but she doesn't have this
house in northern Wisconsin yet or does
she she'd sell her house to get it right
she would sell her house to get it and
and uh she does okay financially um not
great but she has a nice pension setup
so she's in good shape there what's the
sit would you pay rent when you're there
for six months out of the year to help
her cover the mortgage how does this
work no you're just living together like
she's she covers it he does the boat
like you'll cover the boat six months
covers the house 6 months is that the
idea now is there any plan to get
married or nobly not okay you're just
living your life okay I mean we're both
divorced uh her kids are are done and
grown and uh and you're keeping the
money separate like it sounds like
everything is finan very separate I mean
obviously I make more than she does um
so I carry you know the majority of the
burden when we go out or vacation type
stuff now but that's you're the
boyfriend so and you don't mind doing
that it sounds like no no not at all
okay all right nothing sounds way off
here my big question is are you going to
be able to once you officially retire
you're not bringing in more income will
your assets generate enough income to
cover all of your
expenses I would hope so um I've always
you know 25 years ago uh I was gifted
the book The Millionaire Next store
obviously read that and kind of lived by
that most of my life um I I try to live
well below my memes um but yeah I guess
in my mind I I want to have a couple 00
more tucked away before I make this
ultimate move what's in your 401k like
all of your retirement accounts combined
that's what I was going to um my money
market account uh has about 120 in it my
checking account is about 40 um I've got
two uh I or 401ks about 145 um currently
20% of my salary goes into my 401ks I
have the the Roth that I have that I
just opened up in the last uh few weeks
that'll be topped out here in a couple
of weeks um you have catchup
contributions as well so that helps you
yeah and I really don't spend a lot of
money again half the half of my monthly
uh I'm out on the road flying and so all
of my expenses are there my pum is
covered uh my pum on the road actually
covers what I eat the rest of the month
so I have like 450 Allin and diff
various retirement accounts does that
sound about right uh well you've got a
house that's worth about 300 well just
just the retirement accounts cuz I'm
looking at what is actually creating
income right now the only thing that's
doing that is the 145 in the 401K and
some in the Roth correct so I would if
I'm in your shoes and you really want to
live this dream I would liquidate now
take that money put it into Investments
max out all of your tax advantage
accounts put the rest in a taxable
brokerage into index funds and let that
money grow for the next 6 to eight years
there's also the 120 that's in a money
market that's at 5.65 APR
and I still I think okay and you've got
the 40,000 in checking I think that
you've got a lot of money in a lot of
places it would do you well to kind of
get it organized and work with a
professional if you're not already when
I look at when I look at this just at a
glance I look at it and I go okay he's
got 40,000 in checking I'm moving that
to a high yield savings and I'm going to
call that just my emergency fund and
then I'm going to take this 120 that's
in money markets I'm going to invest
that probably into some kind of
brokerage account again working with a
professional then I thought I heard you
say said you had 145 in retirement and
another 140 or so in another type of
retirement fund that's good um and so I
think it's just kind of consolidating
this and to George George's Point
whatever you can liquidate now that's
not a necessity that you're like listen
I have it because I have it but if if if
you really want to make that money work
for you I would work with an investment
professional and get it invested so that
when the time comes you want to make
sure that you can live off of that Nest
Egg you can keep maintain the lifestyle
you have and great
Without Really touching you know the
nest egg if you don't want to so that
you know that you can go you know as
long as possible so that's what I'm
looking at and I would I mean just
liquidating the cars alone if you went
from 54 to 62 you took all that money
and put it in a investment account
making 10% you'd have 1.1 million at 62
when you're ready to retire so just
something to think about to have assets
that are actually generating income
instead of just a bunch of toys but I'm
hoping this dream works out man it
sounds awesome call us from the sailboat
one day that'd be fun that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to Jade warshaw my co-host all
the folks in the booth keeping the show
float and you America we be back before
you know
[Music]
it